pétitions coup de gueule d'anonymes et
des réseaux sociaux qui relaie en masse
c'est le point de départ d gilet jaune
qui auront réussi à battre le pavé
pendant plus de 50 semaines consécutives
en france en novembre 2018
les protestataires demandent plus de
pouvoir d'achat plus de justice sociale
et plus de démocratie directe et
participative
deux ans plus tard ces revendications
restent intactes mais les cortèges se
vide
pourtant les appelle à se mobiliser sous
la couleur jaune existe encore
aujourd'hui avec une exigence
supplémentaire
la levée des restrictions sanitaires
beaucoup de choses qui ne vont pas
notamment points
le caviste 19 pour tous et ses lois
liberticides qui est qui nous empêche de
vivre normalement au rebond est pas
normal qu'on soit emprisonné chez nous
qu'on est qu'on soit obligé de remplir
une dérogation pour sortir qu'une heure
par jour de l'anniversaire du gilet
jaune toutes nos revendications n'ont
pas été acquis comment le reste est
aujourd'hui bien sûr on est là on est là
pour lyon que je le disais mais en même
temps pour plusieurs motifs pour nos
droits on lire dans ta femme tu as l'air
pour les hôpitaux
rien ne va plus des petites le
gouvernement est en place on n'accepte
pas par exemple cette loi sécurité
globale qui est une grave atteinte à la
liberté d'informer on n'accepte pas non
plus toutes les mesures excessives de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sera
confinement d'après un sondage ifop
publié il ya deux mois seuls 10% de la
population se sentait alors appartenir
encore au mouvement des gilet jaune soit
deux fois moins qu'au premier acte le 12
septembre dernier jérôme rodriguez l'un
des symboles du mouvement a tenté de
remobiliser les troupes
au niveau national avec un mot d'ordre
clair la désobéissance civile complète
je le répète ch par un violent comme
l'ensemble des mutilés du mouvement ça
reste à prouver aucun n'a été poursuivi
pour une quelconque jets de cailloux
quoi mais on a quand même perdu un oeil
on est donc c'est que des non violents
qui ont été percutées plombé par par la
police voilà donc oui on reste pacifique
on est là pour revendiquer
il ya des primes aux manifestants
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont intégrer la
manifestation qui sont des petits
patrons de discothèques
c'est pas dans notre intérêt qu'ils se
fassent gaz et parce que ça peut être
des gens qui peuvent être perdus qui
peuvent être perdus par rapport à ça
jérôme rodriguez qui a perdu un oeil
lors de la manifestation du 26 janvier
2019 à vous aujourd'hui être moins
enthousiastes la magie du début ne perd
plus depuis plusieurs mois alors comment
expliquer l'essouflement de ce mouvement
d gilet jaune qui avait pourtant donné
tant d'espoir à des milliers de français
plusieurs raisons sont évoquées réponse
policière et judiciaire dissuasive
restrictions sanitaires liés aux
coronavirus lassitude division d'un
mouvement protéiforme et sans colonne
vertébrale ou encore récupération
partisane et idéologique signe de la
divergence de vue politique
le gilet jaune eric est troué à quitter
le mouvement en début d'année même s'il
reste toujours active sur les réseaux
sociaux d'autres gilet jaune comme
christophe chalencon ou maxime nicole
préfère désormais s'attaquer au
gouvernement pour sa mauvaise gestion de
la crise sanitaire
l'exécutif a été de nombreuses fois
décrié depuis le début de la pandémie
dans un contexte économique morose la
possibilité d'une nouvelle mobilisation
massive et bien là vêtus de jaune ou pas